okay thanks a ok so I don't usually work
in coding theory but this question that
I'm going to mention is a favorite of
mine a I wanted to say that it's
probably the oldest problem that's going
to be discussed here but only just beat
me with a firm missus a question from
1920 so the question is about the rate
of the possible rate of our correcting
codes very fundamental question so by
the way please feel free that's the
advantage of online thing going on you
have a question you have a comment you
have a joke just bursting don't don't
wait so this is the limb soup the rate
of the code this is a code of codes of
bases as the length of the code names of
comes to infinity and such that the
distance that sits in the distance of
say is at least delta x so it's the
trade-off between the distance and the
rate of a cold and what do we know about
this well there is some point i worked
on this problem with good Caillat and we
used to call this diagram the banana
well the answer is that the function
leave somewhere here that's the death
taxes that's the our axis and we only
know its value is at zero and one half
this lower bound is good portion of
which says that our is at least one
minus H of Delta hear the story is is
more complicated and the best thing
which has been sitting there for almost
40 years now is the M W upper bound on
which I've just say a word or two I
certainly don't want to don't expect to
cover this whole a beautiful theory so
just you know
to give a couple of pointers to do this
beautiful stuff so there is a little
southbound the idea there is is very I
think by now the stuff is very went down
the elementary harmonic analysis kind of
thing if you're looking at the function
f which is convolution of indicator
function of the code with itself or
perhaps you / the size of see there are
various obvious things that that you can
say of course you can say that effort is
non-negative this is essentially the
distribution a distance distribution
these two dished means to mean two
different things this is distribution of
C so you can express the concept of your
day the fact that this has a large
distance and you know also what this is
so and and this is a sorry this is
essentially the size of the cone so you
can write a linear program a which would
give you an upper bound on this so every
function like this a lot every function
like this comes from a code we buy and
until now we still don't know what the
the optimal solution to this little
program is that's an unpleasant thing
and and what these guys have done almost
40 years ago is they they used
information about a formula polynomials
in particular the culture polynomial
there are at least 12 different ways to
write this 19 in English a which is so
the post is not technically very
difficult but I say I've been looking
this on and off for many years I still
find it mysterious a there is another
proof of the same set of banned by the
way this is by by providing a solution
to this moving to the door and so on
they gave this upper boundaries also
a different proof which is more
conceptual of the very same proof by
Nirvana and subordinates key but in any
event we done now the value of this
important function anywhere other than
zero and one half let me also mention
another very weak bound and the reason
that you know the bound that you see in
in the first part of a clay shoots at
the third part which is which is this
the sphere packing bound it's a false a
week bound but I just say it's at most 1
minus H of a half Delta we will return
to this later on and this is more or
less say what we know about this problem
and I must say I never really understood
or believe that there is really an a
priori reason why we should think that
this is the truth and fall I know there
will be there can be better bounce there
can be better codes now we come to the
title of my talk which mentioned the
Gallagher's thesis which is really a
very remarkable piece of science from
the 60s in Gallagher a discussed the
following collection of course which
I'll speak about now and and the main
then a new thing that I am I want to
tell you is that a this is really a
completely can be done completely by by
undergraduate math level of things some
stuff that's out those if you teach this
you think you can do this in class this
is mainly what I want to to show you and
they the next thing is that when you do
Gallagher is a proof in this elementary
fashion it suggests really very
interesting new directions which
hopefully will generate a better bounce
or if not we'll teach us something very
interesting so now I'm coming to to
Gallagher's
code so there is a big advantage now now
we're talking just a ganar code and
there is a big advantage when the parity
matrix is very sparse and that's exactly
what Gallagher is doing so this is going
to be n columns here I will see in a
second how many rows the point is that
the row sums every row has k ones in it
every column has j ones in it s'okay
must be bigger than j which must be at
least three i will come back to this in
a second these are the parameters they
are fixed and we're taking an end to
infinity how does it so now it's a
description of this parity check matrix
and and it's known as something like
this so you start there is first layer
they're going to be J layers so all in
all there are going to be j n over K a
rousing this matrix so by the way r is 1
minus G over ok that's very easy to
verify so this is n over K this is an
identity matrix you just simply right
here k and then hit new mattresses and
the next layer is just going to be a
permutation random permutation mutation
of the above and so on you repeat this J
times that's it that's the whole
construction and now we'd like to claim
that each no no no you take these n
columns and you permute them in in a
random fashion and then you do this
again and so ok it's a way so why why is
this a why is this a good code there is
a no I so he doesn't give Gallagher
doesn't give a closed-form formula
neither am I going to give you one but
I'm going to give you a very simple way
to to tell what this is doing and so in
order to so we want to show that
this is not quite a theorem this is a
statement this is a good coat and I want
to do this just by first moment argument
okay so what are we trying so so there
is remember there's are the only three
parameters here are these two integers
J&K would satisfy this condition and
we're thinking of a and large and we are
trying to show a lower bound on Delta
the distance is going to be low so what
we're trying to calculate is the
expected number a so let's call this
matrix a the expected number of X and
such that ax 0 and the weight of X is at
most delta x e that's a very simple
calculation that we want to do and let's
do it now yeah okay okay no no no no no
fine why okay very good hey why why is j
2 y's j equals to no good Jake wants to
is no good because if you have two
columns say took two once per column
then this is a matrix of a graph and
then you'll have a that's the girth
that's a girl no no that that becomes
the girth problem and in a regular graph
you have a logarithmic cycle so we are
not in the right range okay Jake wants
to will not work for us ok so I just
want to carry out this calculation I
know it's like in the day and I know
it's considered almost uncivilized to do
calculations in a public but let me but
roughly still break the code not in that
sense and and do this but you know I
know that you know when I was an
undergraduate in the Technion there was
once an algebra course and and the
students complain that it's very
difficult in n dimensions in the teacher
said ok so i'll do it in n minus 1
dimensions some going to do something a
bit similar i will only deal this cake
was for but really if you understand
this calculation which is which is
really simple
then then you can do the whole thing on
listen when case for the only possible
value is jackal sue but I will not even
speak about Jay but you'll see so how do
we calculate so you just you know make
sure that you're with me because this is
really a very simple calculation so
we're trying to calculate this quantity
okay so here's how we'll do it ok now
let's let's say we do that we explicitly
say that Jake will free so what we want
to do so what is this expectation I want
to ask what is the probability that X
such an X or a vector of weight at most
a 10 is in the colonel in the right come
in at the first layer let's suppose we
know what that is so if I raise this to
the j power and i multiplied by n choose
delta n so if this is less than 1 if
this happens then we're good then this
means there is a good there is a good
code this gives us a code with a desired
property because the average is less
than 1 this means there is such a matrix
for which no there is no a bed vector in
the right no light weight vector in the
right corner ok ok good so the only the
only calculation that we need to do this
is the main thing that they want to tell
you is that this can be done by really
under rugged type nothing nothing beyond
that
so let's do this of course the first leg
said they're all the same let's just
look at the first layer and see where
this leads us we have so have the matrix
that looks something like this study the
identity identity identity and we are
looking at a vector here and we want
this to be 0 how can this happen you see
in the first position and now that that
applies to a this vector has to capture
zero to four of these ones that's it
okay so and the same for every has to
come out to so it this has to come out
to the zero vector right how will the
first coordinate come out 20 well we
only care about these four locations
because everything else certainly gives
you 0 so it will give zero we're doing
everything of course mode 2 if and only
if the number of ones in the in those
positions in this x is 0 2 or phone so
all together you have the following
calculation to do you have to so in the
same and the same thing applies for each
one of these locations so this means
that say you have alpha times a
so altogether you have here a budget if
you want that's how many ones you have
so so these Delta n ones so you have to
say the count of zeros the count of
tools the count of forms the three
conditions they let's call them I don't
know ay u 0 u 2 and you feel so u 0 that
it's a proportion so u 0 plus u 2 plus
you for has to be 10 times e 0 0 plus 2
times u 2 plus 4 times you for should be
delta n because that counts the ones and
then having having decided about these
these parameters now you have to choose
where to put them so so you have to n 0
n over 4 choose these use times now in
those cases where a pic all for I don't
have a choice Zero's I don't also don't
have a choice so I have to do something
likely so what I want really is the sum
of those guys over all choices of you
zeros you to you for that satisfy these
conditions that still perhaps an
unpleasant thing to do but of course you
know a polynomial factors we ignore them
so the sound of the marks are
essentially the same so now you really
have an exercise in analysis you want to
maximize this function subject to these
two linear conditions that you do with
the ganj multipliers and it's really at
the level of homework exercise in an
analysis class and you really get an
explicit expression where these guys u 0
u 2 u 4
very explicit expressions which I I will
not write out but you just solve this
this Lagrange multipliers problem you
have an expression for them there are
just two three parameters in this whole
thing let's say a and B Delta uniquely
defines be then you find a you have all
the numbers that's how you can tell what
this will give you once you again plug
this into into this equation to give you
in particular what it does in three and
four any-any J&K it's just a
straightforward calculation the main
thing is if you understood how this
works it's really just a few lines of
calculation and and and you know what
you're getting one interesting point yes
yes please yeah yeah but this no no but
the somme know they did I sure that
you're right I should have written some
of those up to where Delta and but is
usually where that provides the for this
first moment argument this is the mentor
everything is negligible compared to
this my sins of the probability of the
cold failing I thought was dominated by
two columns being exactly equal which is
the way two things become this no no
that's it's not a problem as well any
not a problem a ok so fine so one one
nice thing that the dis calculation does
so a Gallagher dimensions that these
codes can give you something close to
two killed Osama if you do this I'll be
a Batali close to to get over some of if
you do this you actually get the same
conclusion by perhaps but with even a
smaller J&K so J&K don't have to be very
substantial for this to work and so so
this is more less where this part of the
story ends but now there is really very
interesting challenge which I would like
to mention that
this suggests really interesting
possibility that I don't know how to
realize and perhaps some of you will be
able to do this so the question is why
why do we work layer by layer what would
happen if let's say we bunch them two
layers at a time I want to do the same
thing but now I want to do so my choice
this means somehow I have to make a
clever choice here from the first two
layers and the rest are going to be the
same so I want to look just at this and
understand what I have on my hands so
I'm coming back to what I told you
before to anchor this a matrix 0 1
matrix with two once per column is just
a an incidence matrix of a glove and we
are looking somehow for good graphs so
previously that that was the main thing
that I had to calculate a now I want to
do the same thing and ask a I want to
understand the right cullman of this
thing once i understand this i repeated
j over two times and I go so the same
calculation l everything is is good and
happy so what is this what's the right
kernel of things so the right to now let
me call this matrix and for the moment
so the right kernel some thinking of em
as the the incidence matrix of some
graph so the right kernel of fame is in
one-to-one correspondence with elirand
subgraphs very good
so it suggests the following question
and I don't know the answer to this of
all graphs way that our k regular with n
edges it's a funny way to the states are
the far matters but I just want to be
consistent with which has the fewest
earlier in circuits how many are they
and so on and so forth so you could say
when what what did Gallagher do he also
has the first the first two layers in
his matrix are also two layers so if you
think about it for a second the graphs
that he used is the graph that he uses
here is exactly a random okay regular
bipartite graph that's one side of the
bipartition that's the other side of the
by petition perhaps that's the best I
don't know but I don't see I any up real
reason why that should be the best golf
so the question is can you do better
than that and of course the big question
is can you be so good as to begin with
Shamu so I still have a few minutes I'd
like to it's also so the lp bound is an
upper bound on shoo shoo shoo the lp
there are people there like these stp
approaches for trying to be the lp bound
like no idea what's I will did yeah
exactly with the turbo with it your will
is your alibis yeah I I don't know but
no one knows in the end that includes
rival I I asked you many times of course
that would be a fantastic say buddy
you're now talking about about the upper
bounds I'm talking I'm talking just
about lower bounds I'm talking about
lower bounds so remember what I said we
don't know this function of data for any
value other than then 0 and 1 half in
your question you want earlier in circus
of sizes rooms delta this one yeah short
that's that's the question okay hey I
have some things to say about this but I
put them aside mostly because I want to
explain why reason why and I obsessed
with this question there now I'm
obsessed with the next question but so
this is part of a more general obsession
that I have so I'm trying to you know
explain my problems to and and and here
is one of the total questions I've been
thinking the most about would be really
glad to see any any progress with this
and bear with me perhaps ever for the
first few seconds you will not see any
connection but you'll see they just
momentarily so question it seems like
I'm starting a new subject but i'm not a
how loud find the max of girth of G when
G has inverted says and it's the
irregular so I call this function G of D
nn what do we know about this function G
of DN n is logarithmic in skåne it's at
least four thirds log n bass the minus
one that's lewbert's key phillipson
sonic ramanuja graphs and it's at most
two times log n bass d minus one if this
done we press you because that's just a
in 1.5 factor so think of n is a
function of dmg and then this becomes a
polynomial gap suburbs more impressive
i've thought about a lot about these
things but one of the questions that i
keep coming to a lot is that i believe
that this bound is not tight so that
this tool can be replaced by something
smaller that's a question I've been
thinking a lot about and and I already
erased it and this is because this is
precisely the analog of the sphere
packing bound so this is called the move
bound
and we'll bound is precisely northbound
is precisely the the gothy erotic analog
of the place fear packing so can you
give better balance for kaylee wraps no
in fact I'm paying sure that if you can
do it for Kylie I have specific reasons
to say this but i would just state what
i just said it's presumably almost the
whole problem if you can do it for Kylie
you can do you can do the general case I
will not elaborate but let's do the cake
cases is essentially what what you want
to do so how is this it all related to a
what I spoke about before so we saw this
for example with a way to but here here
is how the story goes thank your graph
GT regular and it is covered the
universal coverage space of this is the
deregulate the infinite the irregular
tree that's suppose that this is a graph
of high girth G so this means there is a
cover map from this infinite 32 this
graph G and you can label every vertex
here by what vertex is it above in the
cabin map from here to you in the graph
G what do you get you get an end
coloring so that's the number of the
vertices of the de regular infinite tree
such that where is the girth condition
coming in how do we see this so if you
think about it for a minute such that
every two equally colored
oh this is a distance case G so this is
a cute is it's a coding theory question
except we usually do the coding theory
of cording theory on the cube now you do
your coding fear and the vertices of
this and you can ask the same question
how large can gdb in terms of DNN and a
as it turns out so what this would tell
you is is this say exactly this this
upper bound remains the same proof goes
and in fact as stated this is tight so
in some sense that that's work that I
did with hooli many years ago so as I
stated this question a doesn't break
this condition however in general such a
coloring general color doesn't come from
a graph and and what's the condition of
coming from a graph it also has to be
periodic that we don't know that that is
the same thing and they think I'm out of
time so I should stop
you
give any conjectures for the extreme
enough for you would possibly know I
don't know I i can tell many things
about how to think about this a little
guy subgraphs a good way of thinking you
really have to consider the cycle space
of off and there is a standard way of
looking at the cycle space of a graph
you take a spanning tree you take the
exterminators every so that's a in
principle a good approach to this but I
wasn't able to to work it out no that's
one of the main problems that i don't
know i don't have at the moment any good
guess on who which graphs would work
here it's also possible that that
Gallagher's choice is the best but that
would also be very interesting to know
think Maddie's this will